[Music]
hello there you're not seeing things
it's an extremely early ps+ essential
video for February 20124 as one of the
games has already been revealed a few
weeks early check it out this is foam
Stars it's coming to PS4 and PS5 on
February 6th a brand new 4 on four hero
shooter that is a PlayStation exclusive
giving me heavy Splatoon Vibes foam
stars is releasing day and date on
PlayStation Plus and then it will become
a $30 game if you don't blame it in time
here's the premise the battlefield can
be covered in bubbles and surfing on
your team's color grants a speed boost
whereas moving on the opponent's color
slows players down essentially making
Ground Control almost as important as
Gunplay the game modes on offer include
smash the star where each team face off
until seven elims have been recorded and
then one player on each team becomes the
star player and acts like an end boss
they have increased health and increased
damage but once they are taken down the
round round is over we also have rubber
duck party which is f star's escort
Mission and you've guessed it it stars a
huge rubber duck which needs to be
pushed forward and whoever gets it the
furthest in the time period wins oh and
although foam Stars most definitely
wants to be an online competitive
experience there is a PVE horde mode to
practice your craft before taking on the
world fo stars is also a hero shooter
with each of the eight characters given
their own weapons and abilities from
Dual pistols to Bubble shotguns to
missile launch lachers and in terms of
ultimate abilities I saw a guy summon a
shark which swam towards the other team
and exploded will foam Stars find its
audience and grow like fall guys did or
will it be forgotten like destruction
All Stars it's totally up to us to be a
success it needs players foam Stars hits
PlayStation 4 free on ps+ on February
6th and remember if you don't claim it
before March it will become a $3 game
will you try foam Stars I'm really
interested to know your thoughts on this
one I'll see you in the comments I'm
you're awesome it's been a pleasure but
my word does it feel weird doing a ps+
essential video in the middle of the
month I'm Adam you're awesome see
[Music]
you